hello everyone and welcome back to the
capablanca saga we are back at the rice
Memorial Tournament of the 1916 played
in New York and Capablanca with the
black pieces faces David Janoski once
again and this is the second to last
game we're gonna show from this
tournament we're gonna show one more and
then we are heading into a different
direction in our capablanca saga and i
know it might seem like we are dealing
with this Capablanca saga for a bit too
long but if you remember prior to a
couple Lanka saga we were covering the
Bobby Fischer saga and it took us some I
believe some five months to cover it
even though we only covered the years
1972 1972 just the palm of the marrow
paint or zonal the candidates matches of
1971 and then the 1972 World Chess
Championship match against Boris Spassky
so I don't I don't think it's a it's too
long but you know we are not we're not
gonna be here forever so and it's gonna
stay you know on on my channel for
forever so we do have to finish it and I
do hope you enjoy that so without
further ado let's check out the game
yanovskiy has the white pieces and he
opens with d4 we have Knight to f6
Knight to f3 by an auskey d5 c4 and now
c6 the the semi Slav we have Knight to
c3 by Janoski
and Bishop to f5 there's been a lot of
talk about Bishop to g4 in this position
but it leads to some of the crazy lines
and I'm just gonna show one that Leah
that comes up after Knight to e5
attacking the bishop and if the wizard
retreats let's say Bishop to a5 now
comes captures captures and E 4 and here
you have so many options as white
already Bishop is threatening to come to
b5 let's say after Knight captures on e4
ninth chapter spawn captures never go
Bishop to c4 already or threatening
checkmate with Bishop captures on f7 and
only after black blocks this would be 6
preventing the bishop from controlling
the d7 square now you give this check
but should be 5 trick and now a lot of
good things can happen for example if
you block here you just lose a piece so
you have to block with knight c6 and
then after Knight captures you can't
recapture because of Bishop captures you
have to go Queen d5 to attack the bishop
here but now just Queen b3 and now you
can either capture the Queen then cap
tonight and you will again lose a rook
as it will be checked or you can try a
six and after Bishop to a four again you
can try captures captures and then
captures here you will again lose the
rook or if you try B five and then just
captures captures in Bishop e3 a white
keeps the extra piece and of course will
win the game easily so this is one of
the reasons why not in Bishop to g4 but
rather Bishop to beef
Bishop to a5 a couple Lanka which is
usually not the case it's its principle
to put your pieces as deep into the
position as possible but here it just
doesn't work tactically so between
between b3 and now Queen to b6 and
couple on conventions that he feel he
felt that this was very nice for black
he will go into a slightly worse end
game but you know if black does have
compensation with the same you open a
file we have Queen captures and b6 a
capture Sun b6 capture Sun d5 with night
capture Sun d5 Capablanca wants to trade
even further Knight captures C captures
and mount III and this is the position
we've talked about yanovskiy has an
intact pawn structure
welcome Blanca has a double beep on but
he does have a semi open file for his
rook to use as he pleases
okay Knight to c6 with the shifted me to
end now a very exciting move by kappa
blanka Bishop to d7 I know it doesn't
look like a very exciting move but it
actually is that when you hear a couple
Blancas explanation he wants to keep
control of the b v square as White's a
bishop also controls b5 he wants to push
his doubled pawn to b5 so he wants his
Bishop to defend this then he wants to
go Knight a5 and put this night all the
way to c4 and white will not be able to
prevent this by playing b3 because then
the knight will have sorry by playing a
three because then the night we'll have
a nice outpost on on b3 and also after
the night comes the c-4 white will have
to give up the light square bishop and
only then will kappa blanka get this
point all the way to c4 c4 so this is
Capablanca splint
now we'll see how he executes sit with
Bishop to e2 and now comes a six the
dark square Bishop is ready to be
developed with castles and now Bishop to
d6 rook F 2 c1 grabbing hold of the only
open file on the board with kink the e7
castling
is also possible but you know it's the
endgame you want your king in the center
of the board not not somewhere on the
Kings side doing nothing with Bishop to
c3 and now comes Luke H to c8 cup of
blanc also takes control of the open C
file we have a three by white and now
comes Knight to a5 so here you can see
that a cup of Blancas plan is moving
forward b5 is the plan Knight to c4 is
the plan and you do want to prevent the
Knights to b3 which would win material
so Knights to d2 and here capablanca
doesn't rush would be 5 first he goes f5
we have g3 he's not worried about b4 if
you try to be 4 to kick it away even
though you don't have b5 o kappa blanka
would still go Knight c4 and now after
Knight captures you would capture with
the D pawn and now this bishop wouldn't
really be all that impressive Bishop f3
just rope to a7 and now it's uh well you
have a backwards a pawn b5 is coming
this rook is coming to a8 you're gonna
bust a bust open the Queen side and
you're gonna play there with the black
pieces
so after f5 I will g3 by an auskey and
only now b5 does capablanca continue
with his plan that started with Bishop
to d7 with f3 preparing efore at some
point and now comes Knight to c4 and now
the b-pawn is under attack you don't
want to do something like b3 the knight
can even capture on e3 so here you could
capture with the night but then again
you get this position and well with this
pawn structure the light square Bishop
isn't gonna be of much use so ya know
she decides to capture with the bishop
with Bishop captures be captures on c4
and now II for a nice principled move we
have came to f7 by Capablanca and now
you have a choice here either you
capture here and then play f4 and then
bring the recover to e1 you can exchange
both both pairs of rooks and try to play
this Bishop and the night against two
bishops or you can play the way enough
skeet played in the game he 5 he closes
the center and he says okay come Blanca
you don't have nothing here now you
don't have anything here I'm very happy
with a draw with the white pieces and
this is sometimes a problem as
Capablanca is the favorite here everyone
was that but still if you have the black
if you have the white pieces you should
always strive to to achieve something
you can do that with the black pieces as
well but especially with the white
pieces with b5 by capablanca his idea is
rook to a4 bring the other rope over to
a8 and then if white doesn't react even
push b4 as there will be a lot of
pressure along along the a line sorry
about that
we have King to have to buy enough skin
and the now comes rook to a4 as planned
King to e3 with rook Sita a8 and now
comes Luke a2 b1 now if white isn't
careful b4 is coming and you will not be
able to capture a character Sun before
because of the pressure along the a file
so rook a to be one and now comes h6
just preparing g5 with Knight to f3 and
capablanca goes g5 nonetheless his idea
is if captures captures and h4 he wants
to go g4 and then transfer the roofs
over to the G side and play there
jános he doesn't allow this he goes nice
to eat one I'm just waiting to see if
Capablanca will capture or or push all
the way to g4 but Capablanca first
transfers the roofs over to the Kings
side who hit rook to g8 now comes King
to f3 and now G captures an F for G
captures an effort and not rook 8a a now
this rook has plans of going to g4 and
then the rooks will be doubled along the
G file and here you could go for Knights
to C 2 then the knight can come to e3
you can go Ruby g1 but yanovskiy tries a
different idea he goes Knights to g2 and
capablanca just continues rook to g4 and
well the best course for white now would
be rook to h1 actually and then after
rook a to g8 go 93 kick away this rook
rook to g6 and then the game simply
continuous black would be better but the
game continues here we had a different
plan
rook to g1 by an auskey and ok you do
defend the night but after coupling has
rook a to g8 which was played in the
game you no longer have the option of
moving the night as you will lose the
rook on g1 so Bishop the e1 with ideas
of blocking the rook pair with Bishop to
g3
with b4 by black cup of lanka sacrifices
upon with plans of activating the bishop
with Bishop to a4 and c2 it doesn't
matter if black or white recaptures with
the bishop or with the pawn the idea is
the same
we have a capture some B for Bishop to
a4 now going for c2 and now rook to a-1
bush of the c2 going for efore and now
you can see that the rooks are attacking
the knight here and because the knight
cannot move that makes this Bishop to e4
check a real problem for white so brush
up the g3 blocking but it doesn't help
white all that much couple blanca goes
the bishop to e4 check King to f2 and
now h5 now the plan is H for which would
force the bishop to move either either
when the bishop or forces to move and
then win the knight on g2 so here you
have an option you can go Knight e3 but
then couple Blancas idea is the same
core Belongers just gonna go h4 and
after Knight captures energy for you
would play pawn captures with check rook
captures and now you would only capture
here the point is defended and
Capablanca would have two bishops for a
rook which is of course much better for
black so after this h5 move enough she
finds a different plan he plays rook to
e7 he pins the bishop and has hopes of
attacking the pink piece with Bishop to
h4 but capablanca calculates properly
Bishop captures and G - we have rook
captures and g2 and now of course h4 and
here you have the option but the problem
is after rook captures and e7 if this
was enough his idea
King captures and Bishop to h4 check
Capablanca will not recapture here on h4
he's just gonna move the King King f7 or
King g8 of course you want to go to a
light Square and now he's just done the
exchange and he will have a much worse
endgame if room g2 a cover one can just
transfer his rooks over here and start
winning picking up the the queenside
pawns
so after h4 with Bishop captures on h4
just attacking the pin piece but rook
captures and GT with check King to f3
and now rook captures on h2 just
rook here is not possible because King
captures rook so you have to move the
rook away from the king
now comes Bishop captures on e7 why
is only down the exchange now and rook
to h3 check King f2 and now rook to b3
so both of Capablanca crooks are on
light squares there and all of the pawns
are on lights were so there are no good
discoveries or or any nasty discoveries
Bishop to g5 was played now comes Kim to
g6 and now rook to e7 going for the e6
pawn but black is faster here
rook captures on v2 check King to f3 and
the now comes rook to e8 just going for
this check and mate idea here look at
verse on e6 was played a couple Blanca
moved away just king to h7 and it was in
this position that Nvidia Nevsky
resigned in the game why did he resign
well after a few checks let's say rookie
7 check King g6 rookie 6 checking f7 or
King g7 doesn't really matter super 6
check King f7 attacking the rook rook e7
check King f8
there are no more good checks available
for white you will have to move
otherwise you're gonna get checkmated
here and then well that's the point is
covering both efore n g4 square you'd
have to move the King but then just rope
to a3 check King would have to move and
then rook to g2 and here there are no
good moves for white if you move the
King then comes well you could try this
but then just check you have to block
and then you will lose the bishop here
and well pretty much any other sequence
losses for 4 for white as well but yeah
it's a really an interesting game and it
really shows what happens when you play
against a stronger opponent he has the
black pieces and you're satisfied with a
draw from the start you choose a line
that doesn't really offer white all that
much and you hope that by blocking
everything you will just force
black to accept a draw but black well
Kappa Lanka tried he pushed he opened
lines and in the end he prevailed but as
you can see here this was an interesting
moment let me just check here after this
f4 moved 1 when I said that after this
copy for move and King f7 that Janoski
had an option of characters characters
and then maybe playing along the e-file
he rather decided to pull the e5 condon
close the position with f4 but now if
you if you look at the pawn
structure here all the ponds around dark
squares and also he has a dark square
bishop on c3 which is basically a pawn
if I didn't tell you it was a bishop you
might have mistaken it for a pawn as
it's basically part of the pawn chain so
not something not something you want to
have but yeah a very nice game and a
very nice endgame skill demonstrated by
capablanca so I do hope you enjoyed it
as well and sorry about me coughing I
have no idea why why why my throat is
sore really no idea and I haven't
prepared my water so yeah the joke's on
me
but yeah that's the game like I said we
will show one more game from the rice
tournament of New York in 1916 and then
we are moving forward with a cup of
Blanca saga not really sure if we're
striking with to the Alaska versus
capablanca World Chess Championship
match or we're gonna check something
other than that before that but I'm
gonna start this out under tomorrow but
yeah I would like to thank Rothman max
trainer Jeff graves Bernard Lou and
Adina Sonoma for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here think all for watching and I
will see you soon
most likely continuing the capo Blanca
saga but if anything important happens
in the world where we're gonna show that
as well and of course I'm gonna check up
on your suggestions and also if you're
new to this channel or new to the capo
Blanca saga the the there will be a link
in the description below the first thing
you will see will be a link that takes
you to all the videos that we've made so
far in the capablanca saga so I do hope
you enjoy that if you're more interested
in learning about 4:0 kappa blanka so
once again thank y'all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
Saturday or Fridays at Friday have an
excellent rest of your Friday